music hey wait quiet up here this isn't so swell I'm gonna bust this joint up say Shawn you'll never believe it what It's an all-new SmartLess Smart-Less
音乐 嘿 等等 安静点 这儿可不怎么好 我要把这地方给拆了 说吧 肖恩 你绝对不敢相信 是什么 全新的SmartLess Smart-Less
Smart-Less Smart-Less Good morning, men. How is your pace? What's your pace like on your walking gate? Like would you say it's slow, medium, or fast? It's very slow. Is it?
Smart-Less Smart-Less 早上好 男士们 你们的步速如何？你们走路的步态节奏怎么样？你会说是慢、中还是快？非常慢。是吗？
I don't know. Will you tell me? I don't watch my gate. You do. I've seen it. I've seen your gate. I would call it... It's pretty quick.
我不知道。你能告诉我吗？我不观察自己的步态。你观察。我见过。我见过你的步态。我会说……它相当快。
It's deliberate. It's deliberate. Your arms and the waist and the legs all going at the same time. Because you did an impression of my walking the other day, like you had like your hips forward and kind of, you know. You do lead with your hips. Each step starts with the throw of the corresponding hip. Some people lead with their breasts.
那是深思熟虑的。那是深思熟虑的。你的手臂、腰部和腿部都在同时运动。因为前几天你模仿我走路，就像你的臀部向前，你知道的。你确实是用臀部带动身体。每一步都始于相应臀部的摆动。有些人是用胸部带动身体。
Some people lead with their toes. You lead with your hip bones. And you throw your leg around the hip socket. It's weird. It's like you can't... It's like a walking dance. Yeah. You can't get your knee out in front of your body.
有些人是用脚趾带动身体。你用的是髋骨。你绕着髋关节甩动你的腿。这很奇怪。就像你不能……就像一种行走的舞蹈。是的。你无法让膝盖伸到身体前方。
What are you talking about? Where is it? First of all, he's not like a walking robot. Sean, how do you... I lead with my neck. My neck is the first thing that enters a room. You do? Yeah.
你在说什么？它在哪儿？首先，他不像个行走的机器人。肖恩，你是怎么……我用脖子带动身体。我的脖子是进入房间的第一个部位。你真的吗？是的。
That's true. You'd be great at like in running a race to break the tape. Yeah. You know what I mean? Well, here's a better description of your walk. If you were trying to hold a brick between your upper, upper, upper inner thighs. And then walk. You'd have to throw your legs around that brick while still clenching there in your saddle
那是真的。你在赛跑中冲线时会很棒。是的。你知道我的意思吗？好吧，对你的步态有一个更好的描述。如果你试着在大腿上部、上部、上部内侧夹住一块砖头。然后走路。你必须绕着那块砖头甩动你的腿，同时还要在你的鞍部紧紧夹住它。
there. It's like something's broken in you that you never fixed. Wait a second. It's your pelvic. Jeff, you, bro. First of all. Right on the top. It works for you, though.
在那儿。就像你身上有什么东西坏了，从来没修好过。等一下。是你的骨盆。杰夫，兄弟。首先。就在顶部。不过这对你很管用。
Last week, we were playing golf. Not with Jason. What? Yeah, I know. Because I was like, I should try it. And I see this guy on the other fairway. And the guy, he was, I'm guessing, I'm not good with age, but I'm guessing he was 900 years old.
上周，我们在打高尔夫球。不是和杰森一起。什么？是的，我知道。因为我当时想，我应该试试。我看到球道对面有个人。那个人，我猜，我不擅长判断年龄，但我猜他有900岁了。
And he was, and I said, look at, we couldn't see very well. I said, look at Bateman and he, this guy, he barely leaning over the ball and even good for him. This old, this old guy, this, you know, getting, getting it going. And I said, you know, the amazing thing is that guy and Jason have the same bone density. Listen, I'm, I'm very fragile. I'm, I'm, I'm like a veal, you know, said it before, you know, it's interesting. We, we finished Ozark last night, the new season, and you getting thrown around like
他当时，我说，看，我们看得不太清楚。我说，看贝特曼，他，这家伙，他几乎没弯腰去够球，甚至对他来说还不错。这个老家伙，这个，你知道，正在，正在进行中。我说，你知道，令人惊奇的是那个人和杰森有相同的骨密度。听着，我，我非常脆弱。我，我，我像小牛肉一样，你知道，之前说过，你知道，这很有趣。我们，我们昨晚看完了《黑钱胜地》，新一季，你被那样扔在地上。我在想，那是杰森还是替身演员？开始了。大部分是特技。哦，真的吗？是的。我现在不真正调动核心肌群就没法系鞋带，否则会拉伤下背部。
that on the ground. I'm like, is that Jason or is that a stunt person? Here we go. Most of it was stunts. Oh, it was really? Yeah. I can no longer tie my shoes without really engaging my core so I don't pull out my lower back.
我明白了。老实说，老实说。你从站立姿势蹲下时如果不放屁就做不到。我的意思是，那是，那是，好吧，那是另一回事，我阀门的弹性全没了。所以，但我已经预约了医生。我开车送你。我更多是在问我的灵活性，我想这是肖恩在问的。
I get it. And let's be honest, let's be honest. You can't get into, out of a standing into any kind of a squat without farting. I mean, that's, that's, well, that's a whole different, I've lost all the elasticity in my valve. So, but I'm, I've got an appointment for that. I'll drive you. When I'm talking more about my, my flexibility, I think is what Sean's asking about.
没关系。我想我得到答案了。我正在安装一个鞋带系统，有点像紧身胸衣鞋，还是高帮的。顺便说一句，这对你来说是个好名字。老鞋。嘿，老鞋。自信点，梅利。伙计们，今天这位一直在耐心等待的人，上帝保佑她。
That's okay. I think I got my answer. I'm installing a lace, a lace system, kind of like a corset shoe, high top at that. That's a good name for you, by the way. Old shoe. Hey, old shoe. Confidence, Mellie. Guys, this person today, who's been patiently waiting, God bless her.
是那种演员之一。你是女性吗？我们在这里太粗鲁了。我道歉。不，没关系。你，她，我太兴奋她今天能来节目了。她是那种拥有每个人都梦寐以求的职业生涯的演员。我知道我有，但这完全归功于她令人难以置信且不可否认的。
Is one of those actors. Are you a female? We've been very, very crass here. I apologize. No, that's okay. You, she, I'm so excited that she's on the show today. She is one of those actors that has a career that everyone dreams of. I know I do, but it's bestowed upon her only because of her unbelievable and undeniable
才华。她有能力，她是那种有能力从一个角色转换到另一个角色的演员。就像一个疯狂的魔术，我迫不及待想谈谈这个。70，抱歉，七。我喜欢这个。七次奥斯卡奖提名。那比我多两次。
talent. She has the ability, she's one of those actors that ability to transform from one character to another. Like it's a crazy magic trick, which I can't wait to talk about. 70, sorry, seven. I love that. Seven Academy Award nominations. That's two more than me.
你现在读自己的笔迹都很费劲。是的。这不是你写的吗？还是？是的，斯科蒂为你整理的。不。她赢得了两次奥斯卡奖，三次英国电影学院奖，三次美国演员工会奖。
You're having a tough time reading your own handwriting right now. Yeah. Didn't you write this? Or is it? Yeah. And Scotty put this together for you. No. She's got two Oscar wins, three British Academy Film Awards, three Screen Actors Guild Awards,
三次金球奖。在我喜欢的许多电影中，她都在里面，我喜欢她在里面的表现，你知道，她是戏剧界的人。她像我一样是演艺圈的人。所以我很兴奋能在2016年的托尼奖上见到她。她不知道，但她是我全世界最好的朋友。是凯特·布兰切特。什么？
three Golden Globes. Among the many films that I love and what she's in and I love her in them, she's, you know, she's theater folk. She's show folk like me. So I was excited to meet her at the Tony Awards in 2016. She doesn't know it, but she's my best friend in the whole world. It's Kate Blanchett. What?
什么？你不可能请到凯特·布兰切特。她有那种技术。你在做什么？你哪来的钱。天哪。肖恩，你是怎么做到的？我喜欢你从肠道弹性转换到谈论下一位嘉宾的方式。
What? You can't book Kate Blanchett. She's got that kind of skill. What are you doing? You're having kind of money. Oh my goodness. Sean, how'd you do it? I love the way you move from bowel elasticity to let's talk about our next guest.
欢迎。她是天才。她是那种仍然能控制肠道的人。你犯了一个可怕的错误。还有70次奥斯卡提名。是的，70。70。你的公关人员说的，凯特。
Welcome. It's the natural. It's someone who still has the control over bowel. You've made a terrible mistake. And 70 Academy nominations. Yes, 70. 70. By your publicist, Kate.
哇。凯特，你现在在哪儿？我在我丈夫的书房里。在？哪个大洲？好问题。我喜欢你回头看的样子。我在小不列颠。
Wow. Where are you, Kate, right now? I'm in my husband's study. In? What continent? Good question. I love that you're looking over your shoulder. I'm in little Britain.
微型不列颠。小小的微型不列颠。小不列颠。就像《发展受阻》里常叫的那样。小不列颠。见到你真是荣幸。是的。天哪。
Tiny Britain. Tiny little Britain. Wee Britain. As the rest of development used to call it. Wee Britain. What a pleasure to meet you. Yeah. Good Lord.
同样。当我在托尼奖上看到你时，我就想，天哪，那是凯特。我不敢相信。我应该走过去吗？我应该打个招呼吗？你当时那么亲切，那么可爱。那是那么。我很亲切。
Likewise. When I saw you at the Tony, I was like, oh my God, that's Kate. I can't believe it. Should I go up there? Should I say hi? And you were so pleasant and so lovely. And it was so. I was pleasant.
我很亲切。是的。但对我来说太亲切了。对我来说那就像是一次终身的会面。我一直想见你。我是你的超级崇拜者。肖恩，对你来说，我的意思是，托尼奖是你的快乐之地。我是认真的。
I was pleasant. Yeah. But it was so pleasant for me. It was like a lifelong kind of meeting for me. I've always wanted to meet you. I'm such a huge admirer. And Sean, for you, I mean, the Tony's is your happy place. I'm being serious.
是的。嗯，我的意思是，你知道，我喜欢戏剧界的人。当然。是的。你是确定的人？是的，确定的人。现在，听着，我喜欢从最开始说起。
Yes. Yeah. Well, I mean, you know, I like theater folk. Sure. Yeah. You're sure people? Yeah, sure folk. Now, listen, I like to start at the very beginning.
我想知道，伙计，开始了。哦，你打赌。你可以睡个好觉。搞砸她。因为我有。我想知道你什么时候做完这部分。不。或者当我们完成整个过程时。
And I want to know, boy, here we go. Oh, you bet. You can go to sleep well. Fuck her up. Because I have. I want to know when you're done with this part. No. Or when we're done with the whole kind of process.
我的意思是，你们。不，因为我不。是什么让你开始的？是的，因为你妈妈最喜欢的颜色是什么？我为你着迷，因为你参与了所有，就像，我知道很多人说像爆米花电影，你知道，它们不像其他电影那样“合法”。而我就想，是的，它们是。你扮演伊丽莎白一世所付出的努力和参与《指环王》一样多。
I mean, you guys. No, because I don't. What got you started? Yeah, because what's your mom's favorite color? I'm obsessed with you because you're in all like, I know a lot of people say like popcorn movies, you know, and they're not as quote legitimate as, you know, the other movies. And I'm like, yeah, they are. It takes as much effort for you to play Elizabeth the first as it does to be in Lord of the
我不认为人们理解这一点，就像。你在问她是否在爆米花电影上和在那些声望很高的电影上一样努力吗？是的。是的。我工作努力吗？你在简单的电影上和困难的电影上工作一样努力吗，简单来说？
Rings. I don't think people understand that like. Are you asking her if she if she does work as hard on the popcorn stuff as she does the prestige stuff? Yeah. Yeah. Do I work as hard? Do you work as hard on the on the easy ones as the hard ones to oversimplify it?
但哪些是简单的？好吧，我想这就是他暗示的意思，假设是爆米花角色和电影比像，像你的搭档，《夺宝奇兵4》更容易。我无法想象，像口音、外表、走路和步态，你知道我的意思吗？这看起来和扮演伊丽莎白一世一样费力。我的意思是，我能做到的唯一方法，我不知道你们，但我总是假装。
But which ones are the easy ones? Well, I guess what I think that's what he's implying is the assumption is that the popcorn parts and films are easier than the like, like your partner, Indiana Jones and the crystal skull. I can't imagine like the accent and the look and the walk and the gate, you know what I mean? It seems like it's just as much work as playing Elizabeth the first. I mean, the only way I can do it, I don't know about you guys, but I always just pretend
没有人会看到它。通常情况确实如此。我有幸这实际上是真的。但我认为，我认为更多的是那种东西，凯特，就像，当你拍那些大电影时，那些巨大的电影，你知道，你知道，那些你走到标记点，摄像机推近，你说，我们得走了。你知道，那些像做那些你真正进入角色深处的事情一样具有挑战性吗？
that no one's ever going to see it. And usually that's the case. I have the luxury that that's actually true. But I think I think it's more that that thing, Kate, of like, when you do those big movies, those huge movies where, you know, you know, the ones where you kind of you hit your mark and the camera pushes in and you go, we got to move. You know, like, are those is challenging as doing stuff where you get into that real character stuff?
我想是的，因为有所有这些你必须理解的套路。我见过，你知道，多一点，你知道，我们在疫情期间有更多时间，但你必须理解那些套路是什么，才能要么颠覆它们，要么在它们之内工作。所以有更多一点，我不知道，期望，当你拍那些更大的电影时，因为你会想，好吧，即使电影是垃圾，他们也有足够的钱去发行它。而且他们有，好吧，他们以老式的方式，疫情前，他们过去常有，他们有。
I think so because there's all these tropes that you have to kind of understand. And I have seen, you know, a little bit more, you know, we've had more time over the pandemic, but you kind of got to understand what those tropes are in order to either subvert them or work within them. And so there's a little bit more, I don't know, expectation when you when you do those bigger movies, because you think, well, even if the movie is garbage, they've got enough money to distribute it. And they've got, well, they in the old fashioned sense, pre pandemic, they used to, they've
足够的电影院去发行它。所以人们实际上会看到这一部。所以期望的压力稍微大一点。这有点像幕布拉开的时候。我的意思是，我在大学时有过一次经历。我演了这个节目。那是一部关于气候变化的音乐剧。有趣。
got enough cinemas to release it. So people are actually going to see this one. So there's a little bit more weight of expectation. It's a little bit like when the curtain goes up. I mean, I had an experience when I was at university. I did this show. It was a climate change musical. Fun.
我加入。是的。它有《雨中曲》。是的。不错。是的。或者没有。天哪。
I'm in. Yeah. It's got singing in the rain. Yeah. Nice. Yeah. Or not. Jesus.
而且它，我们有，我们有一个舞蹈片段，有很多空调。真的，我不会这么说，但在中场休息后，我们有，我们有三个人来看。中场休息后，只有一个老太太和她的手提包。我想她留下的唯一原因是她的代步车没电了，她想看完。但你知道，就像，当你拍电影时，你不知道人们是否会看。
And it was, we had, we had a kind of a dance piece with a whole lot of air conditioners. Really, I wouldn't have said, but after interval, we had, we had three people who came to see it. And after interval, there was just one little old lady in her handbag. And I think the only reason why she remained was cause her mobility scooter had lost its power and she wanted to see it. But you know, like it's, you don't know whether people are going to see it when you're making movies.
好吧，让我问你这个。你看了吗？你看你自己的作品吗？不。你不看你的表演。你是那种人。你看吗，好吧。杰森，你看你的作品吗？
Well, let me ask you this. Do you see it? Do you watch your stuff? No. You don't watch your performances. You're one of those. Do you watch, okay. Do you, Jason, watch your stuff?
我看，这对我来说主要是为了学习经验。当然是。好吧，但你，我的意思是，它确实。不是为了看灯光怎么样。它确实让我平静下来。你知道，无论你是否需要有一点，这完全是学习经验。它对我来说有三件事。第一，看我自己让我平静下来。
I do, and it is mostly for a learning experience for me. Of course it is. Well, but you, I mean, it does. Not to see how the lighting is. It does settle me. You know, whether you need to have a little bit, it's completely a learning experience. It's got three things for me. One, it settles me to see myself.
哦，有趣。第二，它，它让我睡得很香，你知道，因为我的表演太无聊了。然后我也从中学到很多，因为你，你有点记得你在那个场景中试图达到什么目的。然后看到它基于摄像机的位置、其他演员在做什么、灯光、音乐和所有这些东西呈现出来，你得到了背景。所以你希望下次有机会时能更好地校准你的表演。因为你看到了它呈现出来的方式。
Oh, interesting. Number two, it, it puts me to sleep beautifully, you know, cause my performances are so boring. And then I also learn a lot from it because you, you kind of remember what you were trying for in that scene. And then to see it come across based on how the camera is and what the other actors are doing and the lighting and the music and all that stuff, you get context. And so you can hopefully better calibrate your performance next time you have an opportunity. Cause you see the way it's, it's coming across.
但你，那是，有那么多我尊敬的才华横溢的演员，像你无法相信的那样，他们不看自己。这对我来说是一个很好的学习工具。我，我非常惊讶，而且你在你所有的工作中都如此令人难以置信地细腻和微妙。你，你设法在没有任何外部视角的情况下做到了这一切。这完全是内在的。但这也取决于你和谁一起工作，你知道故事是什么。而且我认为，我认为当你参与一个系列剧时，你有点，你是。
But you, it's, that's, there's so many incredibly talented actors that I respect like you can't believe and they don't watch themselves. It's such a, it's such a learning tool for me. I'm, I'm so surprised and you're so incredibly nuanced and subtle with all of your, your work. I, you, you managed to do all that without having any outside sort of perspective on it. It's all internal. But it's also, it depends who you're working with and you know what the story is. And I think, I think when you're working on a series, you kind of, you're, you're a conduit
故事的管道。所以你必须知道，好吧，故事在这个框架里被讲述了吗？但当你和像吉列尔莫·德尔·托罗这样的人一起工作时，你必须给予信任。你会想，好吧，他有他需要的东西吗？他知道他在做什么。我的意思是，对我来说有趣的事情，我想。所以你从一个项目调整到另一个项目？我想是的。我想是的。但这就像，天哪，这只是，这只是，这太痛苦了。
of the story. And so you've got to know, okay, is the story being told in this frame? But when you're working with someone like Guillermo del Toro, you have to give over trust. And you think, well, has he got what he needs? He knows what he's doing. I mean, the interesting thing for me, I think. So you adjust from project to project? I think so. I think so. But it's like, oh my God, it's just, it's, it's excruciating.
好吧，你没时间看你所有的表演，因为你有，你有太多了。我太忙了。你，你是，以最好的方式。我从哪儿开始？但凯特接下来的一年行程非常满，从《匹诺曹》开始，再次与唯一的吉列尔莫·德尔·托罗合作。是的。是的。
Well, you wouldn't have the time to watch all your performances because you have, you have so many. I'm so busy. You are, you are in the, in the best way. With where do I start? But Kate has an incredibly packed year coming up, starting with the Pinocchio, with another collaboration with the one and only Guillermo del Toro again. Yes. Yeah.
正确。不，这是动画还是真人版，那个《匹诺曹》？不，不，它是，它是动画，我的意思是，你知道，吉列尔莫的风格。他要做一部动画电影还是正在做。好吧，我想是的。那太棒了。是的。我的意思是，他，你知道，他从艺术部门开始。我的意思是，那是，那是令人惊奇的。
Correct. No, is this an animated or live action thingy, the Pinocchio? No, no, it's an, it's an animated, I mean, you know, in Guillermo's style. He's going to do an animated film or is doing it. Well, I guess so. That's great. Yeah. I mean, he, you know, he started in the art department. I mean, that's, that's the amazing.
我说话声音太大了吗？不，不，不，不。我看起来像要在得来速工作一样。不，你的音量控制无可挑剔。无可挑剔。什么？你的倾听不完美，但是。我的倾听不太好。
Am I talking too loudly? No, no, no, no. I look like I'm about to working in a drive through. No, your volume control is impeccable. It's impeccable. What? Your listening is not perfect, but. My listening is not great.
它不是。我的意思是，我不知道。你有选择性倾听吗？我被指责过。你是吗？是的。是的。威尔是这方面的大违规者。我是。所以你，你进来时带着一个不合逻辑的话，因为你完全走神了。
It's not. I mean, I don't know. Do you have selective listening? I get accused of that. Are you? Yeah. Yeah. Will is a big violator of that. I am. So you, what you come in with a non sequitur because you just have totally checked out.
他选择他听到的。这是真的。我确实。我经常走神。我确实那样。是的。好吧，我们知道。是的。但我还是想知道，就像，我知道你在开玩笑。我实际上有一个真正的问题。
He chooses what he hears. It's true. I do. I check out often. I do that. Yeah. Well, we know. Yeah. I want to know though, like, I know you were joking. I've actually have a real question.
哦，开始了。好吧。系好安全带。有趣。你知道，我一直想问像你这样成功的人，那些只从一个工作到另一个工作的人。这看起来，而且理所当然。你是怎么在工作间隙这么短的时间内找到角色的？
Oh, here we go. Okay. Buckle up. Interesting. You know, I've always wanted to ask someone as successful as you in, who works just from gig to gig to gig to gig. It just seems like, and rightfully so. How do you find the time to find a character with so little time in between gigs?
你知道我的意思吗？对我来说，这需要一年时间才能想出，我不知道，伊丽莎白，或者是什么，你做的另一个我喜欢的大片？就在刚才，不要抬头。泰坦尼克号。我在《泰坦尼克号》里太棒了。当你在船头和里奥在一起时。我知道，但不要抬头。
Do you know what I mean? Like for me, it would take a year to come up with, I don't know, Elizabeth, or what's the, what's the other big one that you did that I loved? Just now on, don't look up. Titanic. I was amazing in Titanic. When you were on the bow of the ship with Leo. I know, but don't look up.
不要抬头。我转向斯科蒂和我丈夫。我当时想，10分钟后。我当时想，哦，那是凯特·布兰切特。天哪。我甚至没有，这就是关于你最令人震惊的地方，你可以完全体现完全不同的人。对我来说，光是弄清楚那个人是谁就需要几个月。
Don't look up. I turned to Scotty and my husband. I was like, 10 minutes in. I'm like, oh, that's Kate Blanchett. Oh my God. I didn't even, that's what's mind blowing about you, is you can completely embody totally different people. And for me, it would take months just to figure who that person is.
而你似乎，我不知道你的过程。是绝望。是恐慌。那是诚实的。你必须做点什么。你知道，它，它，我的意思是，你们可能比我更擅长，远比我擅长。我的意思是，我，我得到，我想，我不知道什么，我的意思是。
And you just seem, I don't know your process. It's desperation. It's panic. That was honest. You've got to do something. You know, it's, it's, I mean, you guys are probably more better at it, far better at it than me. I mean, I, I get, I think, I don't know what, I mean,
前一天晚上我总是对我丈夫说，就像，你好，我是什么，我该怎么做？他说，你会没事的。但它，我不知道。我总是，我和服装设计师的关系，因为，你知道，你，你和导演谈，但你实际上没有机会排练。正如你所说，肖恩，那就像，我习惯了排练。
the night before I'm always saying to my husband, it's like, hello, what am I, how do I do this? And he said, you'll be fine. But it's, I don't know. I always, my relationship with the costume designer, because, you know, you, you talk to the director and, but you don't actually get to rehearse. And as you say, Sean, that's like, I'm used to rehearsal.
我很慢，慢，慢。我需要那六周和那些预演去说。那不好笑。那没用。好吧。我们要失去这个，你知道，去，去找出它的意思。因为我不知道那意味着什么。是的。
I am slow, slow, slow. I need those six weeks and those previews to go. That wasn't funny. That didn't work. Okay. We're going to lose this, you know, to, to find out what it means. Cause I don't know what it means for that. Yeah.
因为当你创造一个有走路方式、说话方式、口音、发型和完全改变自己的角色时，拍摄的第一天在片场，你必须想，好吧，我希望他们喜欢它。我的意思是，这一定很可怕。是的。所以对于听众来说，你知道，通常，你知道，传统上演员会试镜，所以导演能够看到。
Because when you create a character with a walk and a talk and an accident in the hair and the just completely transform yourself, that first day of shooting on a set, you got to be like, well, I hope they like it. I mean, it's got to be so scary. Yeah. So for the listener, you know, usually, you know, traditionally an actor will audition and so the director will be able to see what
他们这个角色的版本看起来会是什么样，他们会怎么做。然后导演决定，好吧，是的，我们要那个，你被录用了。所以关于你将如何做并没有真正的谜团。对吧。在凯特的位置，她被提供角色。所以导演真正有机会看到它，或者剧组或任何人，是他们实际拍摄的那一天。所以那是他们决定是否要解雇你的那一天。
their version of this character would look like, how they would do it. And then the director decides, okay, yes, we'll have that and you're hired. And so there's no real mystery about how you're going to do it. Right. In Kate's position, she's offered roles. So the first time the director really gets a chance to see it or the crew or anybody is the day they're actually shooting. So that's the day that decide whether they're going to fire you or not.
对吧。对吧。所以它，它，它对每个人来说都可能非常尴尬，因为你可能正在尝试一个完全偏离方向的表演。对吧。那是可怕的点，对吧？那是走钢丝。我想你是说那一刻是你和服装在一起的时候，
Right. Right. So it's, it's, it's potentially really embarrassing for everybody because you could be taking a swing that is well outside. Right. That's the scary point, right? That's the tightrope. And I guess you're saying that first moment is when you get with costume,
当你开始有点感觉像那个人时，因为你开始看起来像你看到的角色，对于杰森来说，那是，你知道，通常是卡其裤和卷起的衬衫，对吧？因为我们得开始工作了。我过去每次在《发展受阻》里都给杰森他的角色开始工作。他会开始卷起袖子。我想我演过的任何角色都没有把袖子放下来过。
when you start to kind of feel like that person, because you're starting to look like you've seen the character being for Jason, that's, you know, usually khakis and a rolled up shirt, right? Because we got to get down to business. I used to give Jason every time on a rest development is character get down to business. He'd start rolling his sleeves. I don't think I've ever had my sleeves down on any part I've ever played.
我不知道那，我不知道那是什么。你一定，你有很棒的手腕。他确实有很棒的手腕。他确实。他有，他有很棒的挥杆。你应该在高尔夫球场上看看他。我们马上回来。现在回到节目。
I don't know what that, I don't know what it is. You must, you have great risks. He does have great risks. He does. He's got a, he's got a beautiful swing. You should see him on the golf course. We'll be right back. And now back to the show.
凯特，你上次真正参与一部有广泛排练过程的电影是什么时候？是的。哦，天哪。我甚至想不起来。我现在有点像有一个。我马上要和阿方索·卡隆合作。但真的，它一直，它一直和他们在一起。
Kate, when was the last time you actually worked on a film where you had extensive rehearsal process? Yeah. Oh God. I can't even think. I've kind of having one now. I'm about to work with Alfonso Caron. But really it's been, it's been with them.
这完全是一个，不喜欢我的口音。但你知道，它真的主要是关于故事和剧本以及所有其他的东西。你有摄像机测试，你可以做几个表情并试穿你的服装。但然后你只需要，我想我能做到的唯一方法就是说，我要做这个。如果它是垃圾，你告诉我。
It's all a, didn't love my accent. But you know, it really is mostly about story and script and all of the rest of the stuff. You have camera tests where you get to pull a few faces and try out your costumes. But then you just got to, I think the only way I can do it is to say, I'm going to do this. And if it's garbage, you tell me.
所以这就是我和导演的对话。我说，所以如果这是错误的方向，我很高兴改变它，但我必须做点什么。所以因为通常直到你走错了方向，你才知道什么是正确的方向。但这通常是在你和导演谈过关于它的大致基调之后。就像你不会做出什么巨大的角色转变，如果大致。
And so that's the conversation I have with the director. I say, so if this is the wrong direction, I am so happy to change it, but I've got to do something. So because often it's not until you've gone in the wrong direction that you know what the right direction is. But this is often after you've had a conversation with the director about just sort of generally what the tone of it is. Like you're not going to make some huge character swing if the general
基调目标是更微妙、更细致的东西。就像你对那种版本有了一种感觉……Satel？这是什么Satel？就是这样。对吧，因为通常很清楚某件事是要么俗气要么小巧。你知道基调是什么。你必须知道基调是什么。
tone goal is something more subtle, something more nuanced. Like you get a sense of kind of what version of... Satel? What is this satel? That's what it is. Right, because it's usually pretty clear whether something is going to be either campy or small. You know what the tone is. You got to know what the tone is.
我的意思是，通常，你知道，就像我多年来做过一些事情，你知道，因为我在楼下还有另一种生活。所以你必须试着把它挤进假期或其他什么时间。所以我经常会在人们已经拍摄了三四周后才进来。所以如果你能看到样片，那是一个，你知道，在过去，那么你可以感觉到每个人在做什么，你可以试着滑进去。
And I mean, often, you know, like I've done things in my, over the years where, you know, because I've got a whole other life going on downstairs. So you've got to try and squeeze that into holiday period or whatever. So I would often come in after people have been shooting for three or four weeks. So if you get to see rushes, that's a, you know, back in the day, then you can get a sense of what everyone's doing and you can try and slide into it.
但仍然……但仍然，就像当你参与像《玉面情魔》这样的电影时，那是一部非常风格化的电影，有一种非常……非常独特，是的，但非常独特的观点，风格上，进入那个，那会让人神经紧张。或者我不知道，你告诉我。或者你是真的知道他要去哪儿？你理解那个世界是什么，它给了你参数，
But still... But still, like when you work on a film like Nightmare Alley, which is a very stylized film that has a very sort of... Very distinctive, yeah, but a very distinctive point of view, stylistically, coming into that, that would be nerve-wracking. Or I don't know, you tell me. Or is it you really know where he's going? You understand what that world is and it gives you parameters that are
容易在其中工作？是的。好吧，我的意思是，吉列尔莫做的第一件事就是说，你想看片场吗？我说，是的。我走进片场，我说，好吧，我不……这一切都在这儿。这是……
easy to work within? Yeah. Well, I mean, the first thing Guillermo did was said, do you want to see the set? And I said, yeah. And I walked onto the set and I went, okay, I don't... This is all here. This is...
我需要匹配这个。对吧。所以，你知道，那是一个……我记得我多年前扮演凯瑟琳·赫本，斯科塞斯导演，他太棒了。他说，你知道，他可以是邦德。你知道，你比她高。你看起来很棒。
I need to match this. Right. And so, you know, that was a... And I remember I was playing Kevin Hepburn years ago with Scorsese directing and he was fantastic. He said, you know, he can be Bond. You know, you're taller than her. You look great.
你不需要穿它。你看起来就像她。我的意思是，那我看起来一点也不像她。所以这很好。我意识到他在做什么，他给了我自由，去做我需要的尽可能多或尽可能少的身体动作。但他所做的是，他给我看了整整……他的《女友礼拜五》和一大堆疯狂喜剧。
You don't need to wear it. You can just look like her. I mean, then I'd look like anything like her. So this is fine. And what I realized what he was doing is he was giving me the freedom to do as much or little physical stuff as I needed to. And what he did, though, is he showed me a whole... His girl Friday and a whole lot of screwball comedies.
他通过给我看那些电影试图做的是说，那就是我想要的能量。所以你在身体上做什么取决于你。但这正是电影需要的能量。他没这么说，但当然那是，你知道，他提供给我的方向或指针。所以凯特，让我问你这个，拜托。你……
And what he's trying to do by showing me those films is to say, that's the energy I want. And so what you do physically is up to you. But this is the energy that I need from the film. And he didn't say that, but of course that's the, you know, the direction or the pointers that he's offering me. So Kate, let me ask you this then, please. You've...
这是一个肖恩的问题。所以原谅我，肖恩，偷窃。所以不让你说出来？是的。所以，哦不，等一下。我们必须做一个侧边栏。不让你说出来。肖恩，我们走得太远了吗？
This is a Sean question. So forgive me, Sean, for stealing. So don't let you get it out? Yeah. So, oh no, hang on. We have to do a sidebar. Don't let you get it out. Sean, have we gone too far?
肖恩，你觉得被切断了吗？你觉得被切断了吗？你没被看到和听到吗？等一下。肖恩，我们爱你。我应该在这儿吗？不，你当然在这儿。不，你没问题。
Sean, do you feel cut off? Do you feel cut off? Are you not seen and heard? Wait a second. Sean, we love you. Should I be here? No, of course you're here. No, you're okay.
你是这的一部分。你是我们能够拥有这一刻的催化剂。肖恩，现在跟我说话。看着我。看着我。之前我一直假装我看不到肖恩。但凯特，你做了这么多在基调上或如此不同的事情。我甚至不仅仅是指喜剧或戏剧。
You are part of this. You're the catalyst for this, for us being able to have this moment. Sean, talk to me right now. Look at me. Look at me. Before I kept pretending I couldn't see Sean. But Kate, you have done so many things that are tonally or so different. I don't even just mean comedy or drama.
我只是，在实际电影和创造角色等的背景下，它们差异太大了。有没有什么领域你觉得我从来没做过，我想做，或者我从来没做过，我害怕去那里？有什么潜伏在那里，你想到但还没做的事情吗？是的。老实说，我想做奶酪。当然。
I just, within the context of actual film and creating characters and stuff, they're so vastly different. Is there any area that you feel like I've never done that and I want to do it or I've never done that and I'm scared to go there? What is the thing that's lurking out there that you think about that you haven't done? Yeah. Honestly, I want to make cheese. Sure.
谢谢你，凯特。那是一次很棒的采访。是的。给我们寄个样品。我想停下来。我想停下来。作为有限系列还是？不。
Thank you, Kate. That was a great interview. Yeah. Send us a sample. I want to stop. I want to stop. As a limited series or? No.
我不希望任何人感觉到我。我只是想学着做点什么。完全不同。我试过陶艺，有点，你知道，但我想要。我们有蜜蜂，我确实想做一些完全远离的事情。现在，字面上，我看了一点关于奶酪制作的纪录片。它看起来确实很有趣。真的吗？
I don't want anyone to feel me. I just want to learn to do something. Totally different. I tried the pottery thing and it was a bit, you know, but I want it. We've got bees and I do want to do something completely away. Right now, literally, I've seen a little bit of a documentary on cheese making. It does look really interesting. Really?
是的。你有点认真，对吧？我完全是认真的。我们有牛。等等，做奶酪？那会在哪儿？是在欧洲还是威斯康星州？威斯康星州。
Yeah. You're being a little bit serious, right? I'm being totally serious. We've got cows. Wait, making cheese? And where would that be? Would it be, is it there in Europe or would it be Wisconsin? Wisconsin.
我们会在这些信息后马上回来。哇，那是一个很棒的片段。我不认为有人说过威斯康星州。不，我们比凯特·布兰切特滴着更多的蔑视。不，那是一个问题。谁来自威斯康星州？那是美国的奶酪之都，不是吗？那是美国的奶酪中心地带。
We'll be right back after these messages. Wow, that's a great clip. I don't think anybody's said Wisconsin. No, we're dripping with more disdain than Kate Blanchett. No, it was a question. Who's from Wisconsin? That's the cheese capital of the U.S., isn't it? That's America's cheese heartland.
看，我有很多要学的。特雷西先生。特雷西刚刚把她的收音机从墙上扯了下来。特雷西只是住在一个奶酪做的房子里。特雷西。好吧，那么如果你做了奶酪强化训练，请给我打电话。我想参与其中。不过让我远离蜜蜂。
See, I have so much to learn. Mr. Tracy. Tracy just ripped her radio out of the wall. Tracy just lives in a house made of cheese. Tracy. Okay, so then if you ever do the cheese intensive, please give me a call. I'd like to participate in that. Keep me away from the bees, though.
蜜蜂？告诉我那个。蜜蜂是我的氪星石。那会阻止我的一切。如果我听到嗡嗡声，我就不能在蜜蜂周围。有一位戴姆·佩吉·阿什克罗夫特在……我年轻时常看很多恐怖片。戴姆·佩吉·阿什克罗夫特在一部恐怖电影里。
Bees? Tell me about that. Bees are the thing that's my kryptonite. That will stop everything from me. I cannot be around a bee if I hear a buzz. There was a Dame Peggy Ashcroft was in a... I used to watch a lot of horror when I was a young teen. And Dame Peggy Ashcroft was in a horror movie.
我想它叫《蜜蜂》。是的。最后有一个画面，她转过身，她完全被蜜蜂覆盖了。我甚至无法想象它。我甚至不喜欢想象它。那太棒了。你和蜜蜂是怎么回事？
I think it was called The Bees. Yeah. And there was this image at the end where she turned around and she was completely covered in bees. I can't even picture it. I don't even like to picture it. It was amazing. What is it with you and bees?
我想我小时候骑自行车撞进了一棵树底下的蜂巢。你甚至记不得它那么痛苦。为什么？里面有可卡因吗？是的。我以为蜂蜜罐，他们一定是指可乐罐。你在外面戴着白色兜帽，把托盘拉出来吗？对不起？
I think I ran my bike into a beehive at the base of a tree when I was a little kid. You can't even remember it was that traumatic. Why? Was there cocaine in it? Yeah. I thought honey pot, they must mean coke pot. Are you out there with the white hood and pulling the trays out? Excuse me?
我不在萨塞克斯。他和蒂娜给了我安德鲁，我丈夫和我，这些养蜂人的装备。我们还没到那一步。我们有凯西，养蜂人，她在教我们。但有一天我会去阁楼，穿上那套连体服。因为他是个大蜜蜂人。我可以推销一部音乐剧吗？不，不，等等。
I'm not here in Sussex. He and Tina gave me Andrew, my husband and I, these beekeeper outfits. We're not quite there yet. We have Kathy, the beekeeper, who's teaching us. But one day I will go up to the attic and put on the link later suit. Because he's a big bee man. Can I pitch a musical? No, no, hold.
音乐剧？蜜蜂在阁楼里？不。套装在阁楼里。蜜蜂在浴室里。哦，他现在没在听。嘿，我可以推销一部关于养蜂的音乐剧吗？肖恩，我们能让你和凯特上百老汇吗？
A musical? The bees are in the attic? No. The suits are in the attic. The bees are at the bathroom. Oh, he's not listening now. Hey, can I pitch a musical about beekeeping? Sean, can we get you and Kate on Broadway?
杰森不会来。他甚至不会看，因为蜜蜂的威胁太大了。但你们两个在百老汇演一部蜜蜂音乐剧？是的。从来没有人做过。你敢相信吗？从来没有人做过。带一个A标记。
Jason won't come. He won't even see it because the threat of bees is too much. But the two of you on Broadway in a bee musical? Yeah. No one's ever done it before. Can you believe it? No one has ever done it. With an A mark.
带一个A标记。看那个。评论自己写。听听你。开场曲会是什么样，肖恩？来吧，给我五，六，七，八。五，六，七，八。我们是蜜蜂。
With an A mark. Look at that. The reviews write themselves. Listen to you. What would the opening song go like, Sean? Come on, give me five, six, seven, eight. Five, six, seven, eight. We are the bees.
你是蜜蜂的膝盖。我们是蜜蜂。你是蜜蜂的膝盖。是的。哦，太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。凯特，当你进来时，你介意当你进来时发出那种嗡嗡声吗？
You are the bees' knees. We are the bees. You are the bees' knees. Yes. Oh, great. Great. Great. Kate, when you come in, would you mind when you come in on that buzz, buzz, yeah?
等肖恩。好的，肖恩，五，六，七，八。七，八。好吧，现在。那太棒了，伙计们。休息五分钟，没人会说。不，听着，凯特，你，就像我在我脑海中即兴发挥的开场白里说的那样，你的介绍，你是像我一样的戏剧界人士。
Wait for Sean. OK, Sean, five, six, seven, eight. Seven, eight. All right, now. That's great, guys. Take five, which nobody ever says. No, listen, Kate, you are, like I said, in the opening that I just riffing off the top of my head, your intro, that you are a theater folk like I am.
你有，我喜欢有趣的戏剧故事。如果你有任何可怕的故事，我会开始。我有一个还没说过的，就是我当时正在。谢谢。所以你有这么多。我有成千上万。我喜欢它们。它们是我最喜欢的故事。
And do you have, I love funny theater stories. If you have any horrible ones, I'll start. I have one that I haven't said yet, which is I was doing. Thank you. So you have so many. I have thousands. I love them. They're my favorite stories.
我当时在百老汇演一个独角戏，叫《上帝的行为》。我扮演上帝。那是一个90分钟的独白。我坐在那儿，正中央，前排，就在我面前看着他，吃着一大袋花生M&Ms，声音很大，只是往嘴里塞。他正在，他正在经历它，就像，你知道，这是他的最后一餐。然后他，他在一把把之间，他在喝一大杯饮料。在我的脑海里，当我表演时，看着它那么大声，那么让人分心，我在想，我能。
I was doing a one-man show on Broadway called An Act of God. I played God. It was a 90-minute monologue. And I'm sitting there, dead center, front row, right in front of me looking at him, eating a giant bag of peanut M&Ms, really loud, just stuffing his face. And he's going, he's going through it like, you know, it's his last meal. And he, he then be in between handfuls, he's slurping on a big gulp. And in my head, as I'm performing, watching it so loud and so distracting, I'm like, can
我能熬过去吗？不，我不认为我能。我停下了演出。我直视着他，我说，先生，你知道，这不是电影，对吧？就像，你知道，这是你在看的戏。就像我能看到你。这不是屏幕。你可以伸手触碰我。
I get through this? No, I don't think I can. I stopped the show. I looked right at him and I go, sir, you know, this isn't a movie, right? Like, you know, this is the play you're watching. Like I can see you. This isn't a screen. You can reach out and touch me.
这是，这是现场直播。这是评论家吗？这是评论家吗？不，不。不是评论家。是斯科蒂。是斯科蒂。什么？
This is, this is live. Was this a critic? Was this a critic? No, no. It wasn't a critic. It was Scotty. It was Scotty. What?
不，不。我在开玩笑。不，不。是某个随机的家伙。但我喜欢，然后我已经告诉你我呕吐的那次了。对不起，对不起。你在舞台上呕吐在某人身上？不，不，不。
No, no. I'm kidding. No, no. It was some random guy. But I loved, and then I already told you the one where I threw up. Sorry, sorry. You threw up on someone on stage? No, no, no.
有人在观众席呕吐，回来又呕吐了一次。是基于你的表演还是什么？绝对。绝对。凯特，任何，任何半娱乐性的故事像那样你有吗？不。我不知道它们是否娱乐。那个，肖恩，非常阿尔·帕西诺。
Somebody threw up in the audience and came back and threw up again. Was it based on your performance or was it something? Absolutely. Absolutely. Kate, any, any halfway entertaining stories like that you got? No. I don't know if they're entertaining. That one, Sean, was very Al Pacino.
哦，真的吗？我曾经扮演海达·高布乐，你知道，显然植根于，你知道，19世纪。而且有一个，它有点，几乎是环形剧场。有一个家伙在用他的手机，我一直，就像，你可以看到光。我们做过这件事，我们把所有的灯都关了，这样我们就能有一个绝对的停电。所以没有安全灯。
Oh, really? I was playing Hedda Garbler once, you know, clearly rooted in the, you know, the 19th century. And there was a, it was kind of a, almost theater in the round. And there was a guy who was on his mobile phone and I kept, it's like, you can see the light. We'd done this thing where we'd blacked all the lights out so we could have an absolute blackout. So there was no safety light.
所以礼堂里真的很黑。他在用他的手机，他想，你知道，也许他是医生。他说，你知道，你说话的方式，你会想，我必须烧掉一份手稿。为你高兴。那很甜。也许他是医生。也许是紧急情况。然后显然他的妻子或他的，无论他是谁，他的女朋友在他旁边。
So it was really dark in the auditorium. And he was on his mobile phone and he think, you know, maybe he's a doctor. He says, you know, all the way you're talking, you think, I've got to burn a manuscript. Good for you. That's sweet. Maybe he's a doctor. Maybe it's an emergency. And then obviously his wife or his, whoever he was with, his girlfriend was next to him
对他非常生气，关于，你知道，他是剧院里唯一的光，除了这个烛光舞台。她从他手里抢过手机，他们在争抢。我能看到。我还在和布拉克法官说话，我的生命即将结束，而且它是巨大的。然后手机在争抢中飞到了舞台上，他的病人一定打了电话，就像……没门。
and got really pissed off with him about, you know, he was the only light in the theater apart from this candle lit stage. And she grabbed the phone from him and they were tossing it. I could see it. I was still talking to Judge Brack and my life's about to end and it's been massive. And then the phone in the tussle flew onto the stage and his patient must have called and it was like... No way.
没门。所以这种20世纪、21世纪的入侵来到了，我们该拿它怎么办？请过来。我感觉太糟糕了。就像，我的意思是，海达·高布乐不是一个有同理心的角色，但我只是想，这个可怜的家伙，他要离婚了。人们来剧院是为了连接，你知道，所以我捡起手机。
No way. And so this intrusion of the 20th century, 21st century had come onto the, what do we do with it? Please come here. I felt so bad. It's like, I mean, Heta Galbra is not an empathetic character, but I just went, this poor guy, he's going to get divorced. People come to the theater to connect and, you know, and so I picked up the phone and
还给了他。但然后那天晚上剩下的时间，当我决定，我自杀吗？我不自杀吗？在我的眼角，你知道，我只是看到他们两个分开了，你知道，就像她离他那么远，而且它是，是的，它是，如果你是我，我应该接听的。我应该接听的。他们会看如果我是你，我会的。
gave it back to him. But then for the rest of the night, while I was deciding, do I kill myself? Do I not kill myself? Out of the corner of my eye, you know, I just saw the two of them split, you know, like she moves so far away from him and it was, yeah, it was, you should have answered it in here. I should have answered it. They'd see if I was you, I would have.
喂。是的。不。但另一个，我认为发生在我身上最糟糕的一次是，是一场日场戏。而且它是一个，你知道，350个座位，而且，你知道，日场戏里有很多助听器，更老更老的观众。所以你听到人们在调频，这样他们就能听到，这是公平的，完全公平的。
Hello. Yeah. No. But the other one, the worst one I think that's ever happened to me was, was a matinee. And it was a, you know, 350 seats and, and, you know, there's a lot of hearing aids in the matinee, older and older crowd. And so you hear the people tuning in so that they can hear, which is fair, totally fair enough.
用双人戏，我们两个小时不离开舞台。有一个时刻我们正在进行婚姻争吵，我们暂停。在那次暂停中，某人的助听器，显然没有调得足够大。她转向她的丈夫说，啊，亲爱的，他们不会演戏。哦，天哪。他，他只是转向我的场景搭档说，嗯，你可以只看着他，他现在停了吗？他现在停了吗？
With a two-hander, we don't leave the stage for two hours. And there was a moment where we're having a marital spat and we pause. And in that pause, someone is hearing aid, obviously wasn't turned up high enough. And she turned to her husband and said, ah, darling, they can't act. Oh, God. And he, he just turned to my scene partner and said, um, you could just look at him, do he stop now? Do he stop now?
在双人剧中，我们两个小时都不能下台。有一次我们正在演一场夫妻吵架的戏，中间停顿了一下。就在那个停顿的时候，台下有位女士的助听器显然没调到足够大的音量，她转头对丈夫说：啊，亲爱的，他们根本不会演戏。天哪。然后那位丈夫转头对我搭档说：嗯，你看着他，他现在停了吗？他现在停了吗？
It's been declared. And she was right. She was totally right. How good would it be to get her, get her a dress and, and mail her your, one of your Oscars would be so great. Or a turd. Or a turd. Or a turd.
已经宣布了。她是正确的。她完全正确。如果能给她弄一件礼服，然后把你的奥斯卡奖杯寄给她一个，那该多好啊。或者是一坨屎。或者是一坨屎。或者是一坨屎。
Or a turd. Shaped like an Oscar. That's how very Halloween. Yeah. Turd shaped Oscar. Sure. Turd shaped now. Does someone make those?
或者是一坨屎。形状像奥斯卡奖杯的那种。那才叫万圣节风格。没错。奥斯卡形状的屎。当然。现在是奥斯卡形状的屎。有人做这种东西吗？
Or I don't know. Do you know, have a place where you go to get those? Uh, what, what, what about, what about that, that theater to film, the television to all that stuff? What would, ideally would you do one, one play, uh, every five years or one play every two years or something like that? Cause you can't do one every year, right? Cause they, they take so much time.
或者我不知道。你知道哪里能买到那种东西吗？呃，那，那，那关于，关于那个，那个从戏剧到电影，再到电视等等这些东西呢？理想情况下，你会每五年演一部戏，还是每两年演一部戏之类的？因为你不可能每年都演，对吧？因为它们太耗时间了。
Well, I did. I did three a year for 10 years. We ran, uh, sort of the de Pacto National Theater in Australia. Is it, you went to NIDA? Is that how you say it? NIDA, the national? Not, yeah, NIDA. Yeah.
嗯，我演过。我曾连续10年每年演三部戏。我们当时经营着，呃，算是澳大利亚事实上的国家剧院。你是去了NIDA吗？是这么说的吗？NIDA，国家？不是，对，NIDA。没错。
Which is, NIDA, NIDA, National Institute of Dramatic Art, which for my sister Tracy in Wisconsin is considered one of the top acting schools in the world. You went there, Mal Gibson, Baz Lerman, Sam Worthington, lots of people. So there's a lot of Wisconsin going down. Yeah. Yeah. Sean's sister lives there.
也就是，NIDA，NIDA，国家戏剧艺术学院，对于我在威斯康星州的妹妹特蕾西来说，这被认为是世界上顶尖的表演学校之一。你去过那里，梅尔·吉布森、巴兹·鲁赫曼、萨姆·沃辛顿，很多人都去过。所以那里有很多威斯康星的元素。没错。没错。肖恩的妹妹就住在那里。
So, so we use that whenever we want to explain something, Sean just explains it to Tracy, his sister in Wisconsin. Oh, that's the Tracy. Yeah. You did three plays every year for 10 years. Yeah. Good Lord. Yeah.
所以，所以我们每当想解释什么事情时，肖恩就会把它解释给他在威斯康星州的妹妹特蕾西听。哦，原来是那个特蕾西。没错。你连续10年每年演三部戏。没错。天哪。没错。
Wow. But it was, it was, it was the, I mean, that's where, I don't know about you Sean, but that, I love rehearsal rooms. I love it too. I think, I just think they're the best. If I was to die tomorrow, not that I want to die tomorrow, but it would be in a rehearsal room. I don't know.
哇。但那是，那是，那是，我的意思是，那是，我不知道你怎么样肖恩，但我热爱排练室。我也热爱。我觉得，我只是觉得它们是最棒的。如果我明天就要死，并不是说我想明天就死，但我希望是在排练室里。我不知道。
There's just something so elastic and impolite. Yeah. The world is so polite. Yes. And rehearsal rooms are not, you know. I love a fart joke. And there's, I mean, there's so many great fart jokes that come out of rehearsal rooms. Right.
那里总有一些非常灵活且不拘礼节的东西。没错。这个世界太讲礼貌了。是的。而排练室则不然，你知道的。我喜欢屁笑话。而且，我的意思是，排练室里总能产生那么多精彩的屁笑话。没错。
You should spend more time with Jason. You know. Yeah. That valve of mine. Do you like fart jokes? Well, it's just, you know, with my, my elasticity challenges right now. Well, quite. Yeah.
你应该多和杰森待在一起。你知道的。没错。我那个阀门。你喜欢屁笑话吗？嗯，只是，你知道，考虑到我现在的弹性挑战。嗯，确实。没错。
So now that is something I have not seen you do as much as I would love to see you do, which is just flat out comedy. Right. Yeah. Flat out comedy. No apologies. You have to apologize. No, we wouldn't do comedy.
所以现在，那是我还没怎么见过你做，但我很想看你做的事情，那就是纯粹的喜剧。没错。没错，纯粹的喜剧。无需道歉。你必须道歉。不，我们不会做喜剧。
Well, you know, I mean, some people try to sort of like kind of half do it, but a big broad comedy, I bet you would just, just crush. Do you have any desire for that? Yeah, totally. I mean, that's, that's a space I love on stage, but it's this thing where film can be really. I don't know. I think I struggle with expectation.
嗯，你知道，我的意思是，有些人试图半吊子地去做，但如果是那种大型的、广受大众欢迎的喜剧，我敢打赌你绝对会大获成功。你有这方面的愿望吗？是的，完全有。我的意思是，那是我在舞台上热爱的空间，但电影这东西真的……我不知道。我觉得我很难应对期望。
And so yours are theirs. Well, both, I guess, you know, that if you go into a room and people expect an outcome, that's what I love about a rehearsal room is that you're going to find out what the thing is. And so you say the thing, the moment you think is funny after three weeks, you go, no, that's not the funny bit. That's the funny bit. Right.
是你的期望还是他们的？嗯，两者都有吧，我想，你知道，如果你走进一个房间，人们期待一个结果，而我热爱排练室的原因就是你会在那里发现事情的真相。所以你说出那件事，三周后你觉得好笑的那个瞬间，你会说，不，那不是好笑的地方。那才是好笑的地方。没错。
And so that's what I'm slow. I'm really, really slow. And Sean can relate to that, but Kate, if I could give you a piece of advice and I can't believe I'm in a position where I'm giving Kate Blanchett a piece of advice, but I imagine I'm your senior in age. I will say this. Of course. Well, let's not say, of course.
所以这就是我慢的原因。我真的很慢，真的很慢。肖恩能理解这一点，但凯特，如果我能给你一个建议，我简直不敢相信我竟然处于能给凯特·布兰切特提建议的位置，但我猜我在年龄上是你的前辈。我会这么说。当然。嗯，我们别说“当然”了。
I mean, a lot of people mistake me for a much younger man. What's worked for me a lot is if you, you, you're setting the bar way too high and what you need to do is really start lowering expectation and I'm, listen, I'm, I'm really, I have a rich history of doing that. So if that's the one thing I can import on you is just really start setting the bar lower. You know, like Daniel Day-Lewis said, he's fully retired. Now, what if you just declare a half retirement, just say you're going to bring half talent. So which half of me retires?
我的意思是，很多人误以为我是一个年轻得多的人。对我来说很有效的一点是，如果你，你把门槛设得太高了，你需要做的是真正开始降低期望，而且我，听着，我，我真的，我在这方面有丰富的经验。所以如果我能传授给你什么的话，那就是真正开始把门槛设低一点。你知道，就像丹尼尔·戴-刘易斯说的，他已经完全退休了。现在，如果你宣布半退休会怎样，就说你只带一半的才华。那么我哪一半退休呢？
Well, just, you're just going to do 50% talent for the rest of your career. And so I've been doing, I've been working on 27%. Don't you dare, don't you dare say that, Kate Blanchett. And we will be right back. All right. Back to the show. Kate, is there like, are there things that you would do, that you do differently on a set now that you've had deserve success over the years that you didn't do when you first
嗯，就是，你余下的职业生涯只发挥50%的才华。而我一直在做，我一直只发挥27%的水平。你敢，你敢那么说，凯特·布兰切特。我们马上回来。好了。回到节目。凯特，有没有什么事情是你现在在片场做得和刚开始时不同的，既然你多年来已经获得了应得的成功？
started out? Like, are there certain things? Like throwing coffee at assistants? No, there's certain things you've admired in other actors that you observed that now that maybe you adopt and you that you were afraid to do before, like certain ways of handling yourself or working or anything like that? Well, you know, I think we're in this time, you know, without wanting to get too heavy or whatever.
刚开始的时候？比如，有没有什么特定的事情？比如朝助理扔咖啡？不，有没有你在其他演员身上观察到并钦佩的事情，现在你可能会采纳，而你以前不敢做的，比如处理事情的方式、工作方式之类的？嗯，你知道，我认为我们正处于这个时代，你知道，不想说得太沉重什么的。
But I mean, we're all been apart and we haven't even processed what the Me Too movement means for sets and diversity means. And, you know, you think, I don't know about you guys, but I still think I'm kind of 31. Clearly. I mean, I know this is a podcast, so I don't want to disabuse anyone, but I'm not. And so you think, well, like it or not, and it's not a kind of a vanity thing, but you think, well, I've made a certain amount of stuff. So you walk onto a set and you've got an expectation of what that kind of quote unquote career brings
但我的意思是，我们都经历过分离，我们甚至还没有消化“我也是”运动对片场意味着什么，多样性意味着什么。而且，你知道，你会想，我不知道你们怎么看，但我仍然觉得我大概31岁。显然。我的意思是，我知道这是一个播客，所以我不想打破任何人的幻想，但我不是。所以你会想，不管喜不喜欢，这并不是一种虚荣心，但你会想，我已经做了一定数量的东西。所以当你走进片场时，你对那种所谓的职业生涯会带来什么有一种期望。
and that you have a responsibility on set to set the tone. Clearly, I should lower that tone, Will. Yes. And maybe that's what I will start to do. But I mean, you do have a responsibility to, you know, cruise. You think about, you know, what Yatsi was doing over the course of the pandemic, I think it was massive, you know, to talk about what crews have been going through and that you as a, forget the story, forget your character, forget your, you know, your fellow Thespians.
而且你在片场有责任去定下基调。显然，我应该降低那个基调，威尔。是的。也许这就是我将要开始做的。但我的意思是，你确实有责任去，你知道，照顾剧组。你想到，你知道，雅茨（Yatsi）在疫情期间所做的事情，我认为那是巨大的，你知道，去谈论剧组人员所经历的一切，而你作为一个，别管故事，别管你的角色，别管你的，你知道，你的同行演员。
You have a responsibility to kind of look after the people that, you know, are working with you. Right. And that's been a big thing for me. Yatsi is the union that represents the crews. A lot of the crews. I think there's a difference now in sort of behavior-wise. We're all, we weren't around at the time when there was what was considered acceptable behavior
你有责任去照顾那些，你知道，和你一起工作的人。没错。那对我来说是一件大事。雅茨是代表剧组人员的工会。很多剧组人员。我认为现在在行为方面有所不同。我们都不在那个被认为是可以接受的行为的时代，现在看来那会是令人发指的。当然，我之前提到过，杰森在20多年前就很棒，教我如何在片场表现，意思是你的角色是什么，人们期望什么，以及每个人是如何在各个部门之间相互协作的，这样你就不会有那种等级森严的方法。
would be, now would be outrageous. And certainly, I mentioned this before actually, Jason was a great over 20 years ago teaching me how to behave on set, meaning what is your role and what is expected and how everybody is collaborating in every department with each other so that you don't have that sort of hierarchal approach to it. Yeah. I was, that's what I was kind of asking is there, was there like a director, an actor or somebody that you really kind of was an influence to you about like, oh, you know,
没错。我，那就是我刚才想问的，有没有一个导演、演员或者某个人，真的对你产生过影响，让你觉得，哦，你知道，我工作得越多，我就越应该采纳那边的某些做法。例如，例如，我之前提到过，但例如，为了做到这一点，肖恩，我记得有一次我在早期抱怨，我们当时在拍《发展受阻》，我说，我一直在问，你们今晚几点收工？杰森看着我说，我们一整天都有你，对吧？言下之意是我们都在这里工作，我们都在这里。我知道你想去打高尔夫球或者什么的，而我什么都没有。顺便说一句，我从来没有任何地方要去。
the more I work, I should adopt some of that over there. For instance, for instance, and I've mentioned this before, but for instance, kind of to do that, Sean, is that I remember one time I complained early on, we were doing a rest of development and I said, I kept saying, what time are you wrapping tonight? And Jason looked at me and he said, we got you for the whole day, right? And the implication was we're all here working and we're all here. And I know you want to get on the golf course or whatever the, and I had nothing. By the way, I have nowhere to be ever.
所以除了这些天接送孩子上学，我哪儿也不去，但就是那种，那是什么东西？所以是的，再次回到肖恩的问题，有没有人教过你那种语言？嗯，我，我是在戏剧学校毕业后的第一份工作。我在卡罗尔·丘吉尔的一部戏里做替补，那家剧院后来我和我丈夫一起经营了城市剧院公司。我热爱那个。
So other than pick up or drop off at school these days, I have nowhere to be, but it is that kind of like, what is that thing? But so yeah, again, going to Sean's question, was there somebody who taught you that, that language? Well, I was, I was an under my very, very first job out of drama school. I was understudying in a Carroll Churchill play at the theater that my husband ended up and I ended up running the city theater company. And I love that.
而这位了不起的戏剧演员叫凯莉·沃克，她在《顶级女孩》中担任主角。我替补其中一个角色，我上场演了三周。我和她聊天，她说，你知道，作为女主角不仅仅是拥有，你知道，大部分台词，它实际上是领导剧组，确保每个人都好，确保房间，房间的基调是每个人都能在其中工作的，而且你必须，你必须字面上领导这个房间。所以你定下基调。
And this amazing theater actor called Kerry Walker was playing the lead in top girls. And I was understudying one, one part and I came on for my three weeks of playing the role. And I got talking to her and she said, you know, being a lead actress isn't just having, you know, the bulk of the lines, it is actually leading the cast and making sure that everyone is okay and making sure that the room, the tone of the room is one in which everyone can work and that you have to, you have to literally lead the room. And so you set the tone.
她做了一件了不起的事情，实际上，当时导演是第一次执导戏剧，因为，你知道，他们经常选角，当有一个女作家写一部关于女性的戏时，他们总是选一个女性，因为就像是，一个女人怎么可能理解一部没有男人的戏，或者有男人的戏？因为这太奇怪了。但无论如何，我们不谈这个。但她说，凯莉做了这个，那位演员凯莉·沃克，她做了一件事，她一直在移动剧本。
And she did this amazing thing, actually, where the director was the first time theater director, because, you know, they often cast, when there's a female writer about a play about women, they always cast a woman because it's like, how would a woman possibly understand a play that where there are no men in it, where there were men in it? Because it's so weird. But anyway, we won't go there. But she was saying, Kerry did this, was the actress Kerry Walker, she did this thing where she was, she was constantly moving a script around.
我和她谈过这件事。我说，你知道，导演真的很担心那个，你不知道你在做什么。她说，我当然知道我在做什么。但有三位女演员以前从未在这个剧团待过。所以我必须表现得像个白痴，这样她们就会觉得，哦，我可以表现得像个白痴。你知道，所以你创造了一个环境，让你觉得，哦，我可以表现得像个白痴。
And I talked to her about that. I said, you know, the director was really concerned about that, that you didn't, you know, know what you're doing. And she said, of course I know what I was doing. But there were three actresses who had never been in this company before. And so I had to act like an idiot, so that they felt like, oh, I can act like an idiot. You know, so you create a situation where it's like, you feel like, oh, I can act like an idiot.
然后你搞砸了，你犯了错误，这样其他人也可以犯错误，这样我们大家都忘了它。然后因此，人们会给彼此惊喜。因为如果你创造了一个每个人都必须表现出最好状态的环境，就像是，你知道，就像括约肌紧闭，什么都不会发生。没错，你领导，你算是通过示范来领导。我喜欢杰森，他总是那样做，他每天都出现，你知道，眼睛很肿，他让每个人都觉得以你本来的样子出现是可以的。
And you fuck up, you make mistakes so that other people can make mistakes so that we all forget about it. And then therefore, people surprise each other. Because if you create an environment where everyone has to do their best work, it's like, you know, it's like closed sphincter and nothing happens. Yeah, you lead, you sort of lead by modeling. And I like Jason, again, always did that and he shows up every day, you know, very puffy and puffy eyes and he lets everybody feel that it's okay to show up as you are.
完全正确。我们都有肿眼泡。那是从哪里来的，看起来你非常舒适地以最好的方式领导、树立榜样、定下基调并承担责任，而且你似乎对成功感到舒适。那是，你的父母中有一位或两位在你小时候非常支持你，并给了你早期的领导意识吗？还是你发现的东西？对成功的人，我知道我显然把你带到了错误的道路上。
Exactly. We've all got puffy eyes. Where did that, it seems like you are very comfortable in the best way of leading and setting example and tone and holding responsibility and you seem to be comfortable with success. Did that, were one or both of your parents super supportive of you as a child and gave you an early sense of leadership? Or is it something that you found? People with success, I know I've clearly led you down the wrong path.
你不习惯成功，我不介意。不。但没有，我父亲是广告业的，我妈妈是老师。没错。好吧，那我会换个问题。当你开始意识到我真的要在表演这件事上做出点名堂，人们喜欢我所做的事情，我得到了越来越大的项目，积累了更多的名声、影响力、资源、相关性，我的意思是，
You're not comfortable with success, I don't mind. No. But no, my father was an appetizing and my mom was a teacher. Yeah. Well, then I'll change the question. Was it comfortable for you as you started to realize I'm really going to make something of this acting thing and people are liking what I'm doing and I'm getting bigger and bigger stuff and gathering more fame, more influence, more access, relevance, I mean,
所有这些东西对一个不习惯成功的人来说可能是沉重的负担。这对你来说怎么样？是的，我想这是，嗯，我不知道，我的意思是，你们会比我更了解。我的意思是，我丈夫对我说了，他非常支持我，但当肖恩提到我扮演伊丽莎白女王时，那发生了，我看起来老了。我拍电影时已经过了巅峰期，我25岁，你知道，所以，你知道，我丈夫说，现在发生这种事太棒了。你有五年时间，你知道的。
all of that stuff can be burdensome to someone who's not comfortable with success. How was it for you? Yeah, I think it's, well, I don't know, I mean, you guys would know more than me. I mean, my husband said to me, and he is so supportive, but when Shawnee mentioned I played Queen Elizabeth, that happened and I was looking dog years. I was over the hill by the time I made a movie, I was 25, you know, and so, you know, my husband said, it's great that this is happening now. You've got five years, you know that.
然后就没关系了，你可以回到剧院。所以我一直，这就是我一直对自己说的，你知道，当它来的时候我就接受它。然后我有另一件我热爱的事情，那就是，你知道，我真正的工作在等着我。你也非常非常擅长那件事。而且实际上这个，肖恩，这个问题是给你的。听凯特说话，因为我想听凯特的输入，嗯，这是两部分。
And then it's okay, you can go back to the theater. And so I've always, that's what I've always said to myself is like, you know, I'll take it when it comes. And then I've got this other thing that I love, which is, you know, my real job is waiting for me. That you're also really, really good at. And actually this, Sean, this question is for you. Hearing Kate talk, and because I want to hear Kate, your input, well, it's two parts.
凯特，那种经历是什么样的？你以一种非常崇敬的态度谈论你在悉尼经营剧院的经历。肖恩，那是什么样的？你能，比如，那会是你的梦想吗，肖恩？当她提到经营剧院时，你眼睛都亮了。你想知道吗？不，我只是觉得他们，当你拥有一家剧院，你经营一家剧院什么的，这很酷。
Kate, what was that experience like? And you sort of speak very reverentially about this experience of working in the theater and running the theater when you did it in Sydney. Sean, what was that like? And could you, like, would that be your dream, Sean? When she mentioned running the theater, you like lit up. Would you like to know? No, I just think it's cool that they, when you own a theater, you run a theater or something.
我只是觉得这样回馈社会真的很棒，因为我，我最早的，我感到安全、做自己并被包容在孩子所需的所有那些事情中的第一个地方就是剧院。那是索尼克吗？是的，完全是。我会逃课。你说什么，威尔？是索尼克吗？
I just think that's really great to give back like that because I, one of my first, the first place I ever felt safe to be me and included in all of those things that a human needs as a child was the theater. Was that Sonic? Yeah, totally. I would cut class. What'd you say, Will? Was it Sonic?
是索尼克吗？是索尼克的免下车餐厅吗？被烫伤了。抱歉。免下车餐厅。理解并削弱。没错。这就是友谊的全部意义。
Was it Sonic? Was it the drive-thru at Sonic? Getting a burn. Sorry. Drive-thru. Understood and undercut. Yeah. That's what friendship's all about.
没错。但是的，这是我的爱的语言。这是我的爱的语言。那是谎言。在索尼克的队伍里。不。但谢谢你的提问，威尔。没错。
Yeah. But yeah, it's my love language. This is my love language. That's a lie. In the line of Sonic. No. But thanks for asking, Will. Yeah.
不，我想那是，我会逃课，高中时就去剧院坐着，因为它太安静、太祥和了，还有那种气味，以及我在那里结识的所有朋友的记忆，通过那个你可以失败、每个人都会笑并为你欢呼让你继续尝试的空间。没错。而那是，凯特，你实际上说你以一种稍微不同的方式在谈论。看起来剧院，那种经历是你的安全空间或快乐空间，以一种
No, I think that that's, I would cut class in high school and just go sit in the theater because it was so quiet and peaceful and the smell and then all the memories of all the friends that I made there through the safe space where you could fail and everybody would laugh and cheer you on to just keep trying it again. Yeah. And that's kind of, Kate, you actually said you're talking in a little bit of a different way. It seems like that the theater, that experience is your safe place or your happy place in
方式。你一直说，我会回去。如果其他一切都分崩离析，我会回到那里。那是你的安全空间吗？是的。嗯，我的意思是，我想这就是我热爱《玉面情魔》的原因，因为它就像我总是认为剧院是马戏团。就像我在高中时一起做戏剧的所有人，我至今仍是朋友。
a way. You keep saying like, I'll go back. If everything else falls apart, I'll go back to that. Is it your safe space? Yeah. Well, I mean, I think that's what I loved about Nightmare Alley is it's like I always think about the theater as being circus. It's like all the people I made, theater with high school, I'm still friends with.
一样。没错。在大学也是，因为在青春期那个阶段，你会说，我不知道。我不知道我胸前长出来的这些东西是什么。这真的很奇怪。你知道，我的意思是，你可能，你们都没有那个问题，但，你知道，那不是问题。
Same. Yeah. And at university because it's at that point when you were an adolescent where you go, I don't know. I don't know what these things that are growing on my chest are. It's really weird. You know, it's like, I mean, you probably, none of you had that problem, but, you know, it's not a problem.
我有很多糖或盐，我会口渴，无论如何。没错，你可能会。或者，你知道，如果你吃不是有机的鸡肉，我有一个演员朋友来找我，他当时在演哈姆雷特，他说，我长出了乳房。没错。我说，什么？他说，我长出了乳房，我说，他说，我最近吃了很多鸡肉。所以他真的很担心，因为他在演哈姆雷特。
I have a lot of sugar or salt, I will get thirsty anyway. Yeah, you may. Or, you know, if you eat chicken that's not organic, I had an active friend of mine who came to me, he was playing Hamlet and he said, I'm crying breasts. Yeah. I said, what? He said, I'm crying breasts and I said, he said, I've been eating a lot of chicken lately. And so he was really worried because he's playing Hamlet.
杰森吃切碎的鸡肉。等等，我一直吃鸡肉。那可能是吗？但它需要和那些鸡被注射的所有激素一起。没错。它可能有。但如果我吃腿或大腿呢？如果我停止吃鸡胸肉，那会……
Jason eats chopped chicken. Wait, I eat chicken all the time. Could that be? But it needs to be with all those hormones that the chickens are pumped with. Yeah. It can have. But what about if I eat the leg or the thigh? If I stop eating the chicken breasts, will that...
不，那和它没关系。如果你吃动物的身体部位，你不会长出那个身体部位。那是……那就像整天问大腿的问题。嗯，我把它抛出来，你知道，我不怕给别人设置一个好的、简单的球。我可以问关于表演和吸引力的问题吗？但是，因为我们这里都是演员，不是要进入一个大的演员话题，但我真的很享受关于表演的部分。
No, it's nothing to do with it. If you eat the body part of the animal, you don't grow that body part. It's... That was like the question of a thigh all day. Well, I lob it up, you know, I'm not afraid to set someone up for a nice, easy one. Can I ask about acting and the draw? But like, because we're all actors here and not to get into a big actor thingy, but I really enjoy the part about acting.
我先说，我喜欢通过我扮演的角色来探索我自己的不同领域。是那样吗？这对你来说是一种内在的探索，还是它的吸引力，令人兴奋的部分更多是关于扮演与你完全不同的人并变形成一个完全不同的人？还是你喜欢检查你自己怪癖的边界？没错。
I'll go first saying that I like to kind of explore the different areas of myself by which characters that I'm playing. Is that something? Is it an internal exploration for you or is the draw of it, the exciting part of it more about playing people that are completely different than you and morphing into a completely different person? Or do you like checking out the boundaries of your own eccentricities? Yeah.
看，杰森，你真的很有趣。我是。这就是我试图告诉这些家伙的。他任务完成了。他确实说他喜欢调查他自己的不同领域（单数）。继续。抱歉，凯特。我们有腋下。
See, Jason, you're really interesting. I am. This is what I try to tell these guys. Mission accomplished for him. He did say he likes to investigate the different area singular of himself. Go ahead. Sorry, Kate. We have the armpit.
不，我的意思是，我对我自己一点兴趣都没有。所以它总是……我不知道，它有点像社会人类学，但你可以对此变得有点数学化，而且你必须让它物理化。如果我有时间重来。我会和皮娜·鲍什一起工作，或者我会成为一名舞踏舞者，或者它是所有那些东西的物理化，我完全可以去工作。我不能……
No, I mean, I couldn't be less interested in myself. So it's always the... I don't know, it's kind of like social anthropology, but you get to be a little bit mathogram about it and you have to make it physical. I had my time over. I would work with Pina Bausch or I'd be a buto dancer or it's the physicalization of all of that stuff that I just completely get to work. I couldn't...
我谈论我自己或调查我的腋下。我的意思是，真的。所以你就像变形成一个完全不同的人，是吗？没错。嗯，这只是别人的经历。而且看，我不知道你怎么样，但我的意思是，你和角色之间有任何平行或交叉点。它会坐在那里。
I talked about myself or investigating my armpits. I mean, really. So you're like morphing into a completely different person, yeah? Yeah. Well, it's just someone else's experience. And look, I don't know about you, but I mean, there's any parallel or intersection between you and the character. It's going to sit there.
而且你无法逃避你自己，特别是随着年龄的增长，你作为一个人类确实会钙化一点，这很不幸，但它变得……我记得辛迪·舍曼说她最近在她的作品中转向了数字化。每个人都说，哦，天哪，辛迪·舍曼怎么可能转向数字化，而她一直都是关于相机内的转换。她说，嗯，我到了一个我是一个不那么塑料的物体的地步。我不能……所以我需要继续玩弄这种形式，你必须随着年龄的增长找到那种方式
And you can't escape yourself, particularly as one gets older, you do calcify a little bit as a human, which is unfortunate, but it becomes... I remember Cindy Sherman saying she went digital relatively recently in her body of work. And everyone was like, oh, my God, how can Cindy Sherman possibly go digital and was all about her doing in-camera transformations. And she said, well, I got to the point where I was a less plastic object. I couldn't... And so I needed to keep playing with the form and you have to find that way as you get older
去，我不知道，逃避你自己。没错。但就像鲍勃·迪伦，当他在纽波特民谣节插上电时，每个人都吓坏了，但他并没有停止成为鲍勃·迪伦。他只是开始成为鲍勃·迪伦的一个不同版本，因为他也病了。你知道我注意到了什么，凯特，我喜欢……我扮演过鲍勃·迪伦。没错。
to, I don't know, escape yourself. Yeah. But like Bob Dylan, when he went electric at the Newport Jazz Festival and everybody freaked out, and he didn't stop being Bob Dylan. He just started being a different version of Bob Dylan because he was sick too. And you know what I noticed, Kate, that I like... That I played Bob Dylan. Yeah.
那太疯狂了。你扮演过鲍勃·迪伦。我扮演过鲍勃·迪伦。没错。那太疯狂了。那太棒了。没错。就像我是鲍勃·迪伦的首选人。
That's crazy. You played Bob Dylan. I played Bob Dylan. Yeah. That is crazy. That's so great. Yeah. It's like I'm the go-to person with Bob Dylan.
所以托德·海因斯，前段时间，拍了一部关于鲍勃·迪伦的电影，并把他分开了，因为显然他是一个变形者。当然。我的意思是，你知道，他是我所有的英雄之一。没错。但你知道……所以他想要某个人……因为你描述的那个电子时期太标志性了……
So Todd Haynes, a while ago, made a film about Bob Dylan and divided him, because obviously he's such a shapeshifter. Sure. I mean, you know, he's one of my all-time heroes. Yeah. But you know... And so he wanted someone... Because that electric period you described is so iconic...
标志性。……他想要一个女人来扮演它，因为，你知道……凯特，让我问你一个这些家伙会因为我问任何在这一行有你这么多年的演员而嘲笑我的问题，但有了那种经验，有了那种片场时间，你有任何导演的愿望吗，去利用你所吸收的一切并把它投入到那个领导位置，从而让片场的每一天比一个经验较少的初学者更顺利？嗯，我一直在远处看着你，先生，而且，你知道，你一直在做的事情
Iconic. ...that he wanted a woman to play it because, you know... Kate, let me ask you a question that these guys will make fun of me for asking any actor that's been blessed with as many years as you've had in this business, but with that experience, with that set time, do you have any desire to direct, to use all that you have absorbed and put it into that leadership position and consequently make the day smoother for everyone on set than perhaps a first-timer with less experience? Well, I have been watching you from afar, Senor, and, you know, what you have been doing
而且，你知道，那种……通过表演、制作到导演的旅程。她转移话题的方式。而且你和乔尔合作过，了不起的乔尔……哦，天哪，他太棒了。我喜欢那部电影。他在《礼物》中做得太棒了。没错。《礼物》太棒了。
and, you know, the kind of... the journey through acting, producing, to directing. The way she deflects. And you've worked with Joel, wonderful Joel... Oh, God, he's so good. I love that film. What a great job he did with the gift. Yeah. The gift was fantastic.
我喜欢那部电影。你在那里面也演得非常出色。谢谢你，夫人。人们以前也问过我，但我的……我认为这也是品味的问题，就像，你知道，当你和吉列尔莫合作，和安娜·麦凯合作，和斯科塞斯合作时，他们知道如何执导。所以我已经在剧院里了，我不知道你有没有，肖恩，但我已经在剧院里了，因为我理解这个过程。
I love that movie. You were mighty fine in that, too. Thank you, Mrs. And people have asked me before, but my... I think it's a question of taste, too, like, you know, when you work with Guillermo and you work with Anna McKay and you work with Scorsese, they know how to direct. So I have in theatre, I don't know if you have, Sean, but I have in theatre because I understand the process.
没错。而且我想我只是在等待那个不可否认的东西，我想，你知道，我完全理解这一点，但我不能参与其中。但我记得和马特·达蒙谈过这件事，你知道，他非常聪明，有编剧的大脑和非常棒的导演眼光。是的，我也很想看他做。没错，完全正确。但无论……你参与其中吗？
Right. And I think I'm just waiting for that undeniable thing, which I think, you know, I understand this completely, but I can't be in it. But I remember talking to Matt Damon about this, you know, who is so smart and has such a rider's brain and a really great director's eye. Yeah, I'd love to see him do it, too. Yeah, exactly. But whether...are you in it?
因为作为一名演员……我不知道。你可能在《黑钱胜地》中发现了这一点，就是你身处其中。所以你理解它需要如何调度，场景需要如何被看待。你理解角色的视角，因为你经历过它。所以，因此，你不应该为……我不是说你为那个感到羞耻，但它就像……哦，天哪。
Because as an actor... I don't know. You've probably found this with Ozark, is that you are inside the thing. So you understand how it needs to be blocked, how the scene needs to be looked at. You understand the character's perspectives because you've lived it. So, therefore, you shouldn't be ashamed of... I'm not saying you are ashamed of that, but it's like... Oh, God.
不，但它就像你……这发生了一个转折，这发生了一个真正的转折。没错，这发生了……但无论如何……我有主意了，凯特，关于你将要执导的电影。它将结合我们谈论过的你真正……我认为你热爱的两件事，那就是蜜蜂和奶酪，它叫《奶酪守护者》。
No, but it's like you... This took a turn, this took a real turn. Yeah, this took the... But anyway... I've got the idea. I've got the idea, Kate, for your film that you're going to direct. And it's going to combine two of the things that we've talked about that you really...that I think you love, which are bees and cheese, and it's called the cheesekeeper.
好的。而且……没错。我太兴奋了。这个圣诞节，踏上一段前往威斯康星州绿湾中心的旅程。来自带给你特蕾西的人们。好的。它是《奶酪守护者》。
Okay. And... Yeah. I'm so excited. This Christmas, go on a journey to the heart of Green Bay, Wisconsin. From the people who brought you Tracy. Okay. It's the cheesekeeper.
凯特，我们留你太久了。太久了，太久了。上帝保佑你。我两秒钟后就让你走。我需要崇拜一下。哦，天哪，《指环王》是我最喜欢的书系列之一。我很高兴你在里面。因为那个，你在我心中永远是一个支柱。
Kate, we've kept you way too long. Way too long, way too long. God bless you. I'm going to let you go in two seconds. I need to fan out. Oh, my God, Lord of the Rings is one of my favorite books, series. I'm so glad you are in it. You are a staple in my mind forever because of that.
而且作为一个孩子，《墙上有一个钟的房子》，我小时候读过所有那些书。我也是。我也是。是的。我太喜欢那些书了。看到你扮演齐默尔曼夫人，她是我有史以来最喜欢的童书角色之一。这真是……看到你在上面真是太不可思议了。
And as a kid, a house with a clock in its walls, I read all of those books as a kid. Me too. Me too. Yes. I loved those books so much. And to see you play Mrs. Zimmerman, who is one of my favorite characters in any kid's book of all time. It was such...it was so incredible to see you up there.
但无论如何，谢谢你来到这里。给你满满的爱。谢谢。也谢谢你所有不可思议的作品。请继续努力，越来越努力。永远不要停止。请给我们更多更多。是的。
But anyway, thank you for being here. Lots of love to you. Thank you. And thank you for all of your incredible work. Please keep going harder and harder. Don't ever stop. Give us more and more, please. Yes.
没错，你太棒了，凯特。非常感谢。你们三位也一样。谢谢你们答应参加这个节目。再见，亲爱的。再见。再见。谢谢。
Yeah, you're so great, Kate. Thank you so much. Ditto to the three of you. Thank you for saying yes to this. Bye, sweetie. Bye. Bye. Thank you.
谢谢邀请我。再见。我本可以问她五百万个问题。我不认为你能想出五百万个问题，我要对你实话实说。不，说真的。《指环王》和《霍比特人》，哦，天哪，她在里面太棒了。我喜欢那些电影。
Thanks for having me. Bye. I could have asked her five million questions. I don't think you could have come up with five million questions, and I'm gonna be real with you. No, seriously. Lord of the Rings and the Hobbit, oh my God, she's amazing in those. I love those movies.
没错。这一切是怎么促成的，肖恩？我的意思是，你手里有她的一些破坏性照片什么的吗？她一直在我的名单上，榜首，很长一段时间……自从我们开始这个播客以来。你羞辱她才参加的吗？没错。我爱她。我觉得她太棒了。
Yeah. How did that all come together, Sean? I mean, do you have some damaging photos on her or something? She's been on my list, top of the list, for a long...since we started this podcast. Did you shame her into this? Yeah. I love her. I think she's amazing.
我觉得她……没错。我的意思是……当然。就像梅丽尔·斯特里普和她，还有……我们从来没让她说布拉德利的坏话。她应该说的，因为那会很有趣。没错，那会……让我们把她叫回来。
I think she's... Yeah. I mean... Of course. Like Meryl Streep and her and... We never did get her to talk shit on Bradley. She should have, because that would have been good. Yeah, that would...let's call her back.
她什么时候和布拉德利合作的？在现在上映的她正在宣传的那部电影里，你这个笨蛋……哦，那部。没错。该死的，肖恩。肖恩，我们也不会剪掉那个。那会保留下来。我忘了。
When did she work with Bradley? In the film that's out right now that she's promoting you stupid... Oh, that one. Yeah. God damn it, Sean. Sean, we're not cutting that out either. That's staying in. I forgot.
我忘了。我会说，凯特是……我的意思是，那是一个非常有才华、非常有才华的人。我的天，在每件事里都那么好，而且那么多样化。没错。我不能……再见！不。突然之间。
I forgot. I will say, Kate is...I mean, that is a talented, talented person. My word is so good in everything and so diverse. Yeah. I can't... Bye! No. Just out of nowhere.
什么鬼？带着所有的……等等，杰森。我对此感到非常冒犯。没错。杰森正要……他得去尿尿。抱歉。
What the fuck? With all of... Hang on, Jason. I'm so offended by that. Yeah. Jason was about to... He has to go pee. I'm sorry.
我确实得去尿尿。那么，我们都见过她因之获得奖励和奖项的所有那些不可思议的表演呢？她从来没看过其中任何一个。没错。那不是很疯狂吗？我知道。那很疯狂。
I do have to pee. So, what about all those incredible performances that we have all seen that she has been rewarded for and awarded for? She has never seen any of them. Yeah. Isn't that wild? I know. That's wild.
没错。她从来没看过她的任何电影，她的任何角色，这是我从她的回答中得出的结论。我不敢相信那是100%真实的，但听起来它可能是。我的意思是，《本杰明·巴顿奇事》、《灰姑娘》、《雷神》、《瞒天过海：美人计》，我的意思是，她演过无数巨大的电影。我的意思是……《天才瑞普利》，记得那个吗？那太不可思议了。
Yeah. She's never seen any of her movies, any of her roles is what I'm taking from her answer. I can't believe that that's 100% true, but it sounds like it could be. I mean, Benjamin Button, Cinderella, Thor, Oceans 8, I mean, she's been in tons of huge movies. I mean... Talented Mr. Ripley, remember that? That's incredible.
不可思议。她合作过的人。难以置信。我知道。无论如何。不可思议的嘉宾，肖恩。哇。嗯，谢谢。
Incredible. She's worked with. Unbelievable. I know. Anyway. Incredible guest, Sean. Wow. Well, thanks.
没错，肖恩。谢谢你。我很高兴我们见面了。所以叫什么名字？只需点击……只需点击你获取播客的地方下方，你知道的。没错。然后我就不必了。
Yeah, Sean. Thank you for that. I'm glad yeah we met. So what's called again? Just click and... Just click below where you get your podcast, you know. Yeah. Then I don't have to.
再见。再见。再见。它是免费的。聪明。一次。聪明。一次。
Bye. Bye. Bye. It's free. Smart. Once. Smart. Once.
聪明。一次。SmartLess是由迈克尔·格兰特·特里、罗布·阿姆贾尔夫和本内特·巴贝科100%有机且手工制作的。SmartLess。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。
Smart. Once. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjalf and Bennett Barbeco. SmartLess. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
聪明。一次。SmartLess是由Michael Grant Terry、Rob Armjalf和Bennett Barbeco百分之百有机且手工制作的。SmartLess。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。